hi everyone Sal Khan here and I just
wanted to invite you or tell you a
little bit about our course on U.S
government in Civics the first question
you might be wondering is why do I need
to learn about government in Civics and
what I would tell you is because you are
a member of our democracy a democracy
does not work unless the people who make
up the Democracy are willing to be
informed willing to understand what
rights they have and potentially what
rights they give up in order to have a
better functioning Society so if we want
to function it as a society you should
pay attention to this course and just so
you know what this covers we start with
the foundations of American democracy
how did we get to where we are you might
not appreciate it you might say oh
democracy goes all the way back to the
ancient Greeks but the reality is the
modern form of democracy really started
with American democracy and then it has
been replicated throughout the world so
understand the tensions that the
founders faced and how they got to a
pretty nice balance that's at least
worked for several hundred years
then we're going to talk about
interactions amongst the branches of
government some of y'all have heard
about checks and balances the Executive
Branch the judicial branch the
legislative branch legislative branch
how does all of that work together then
civil liberties and civil rights what
are your rights what are other people's
rights how do we make sure that they are
guarded by things like the Bill of
Rights and also more modern versions of
What civil liberties and civil rights
actually mean then we talk about
citizenship you might just think about
citizenship as a bunch of privileges you
get a decision as a citizen but there's
also some obligations so think about
that a little bit and then we're going
to talk about ideologies and beliefs
politics things like political parties
which you're probably familiar with
maybe even tired of hearing about but it
never hurts to be armed with more
information and then how do you become a
better participant in our democracy the
topic of political participation and
then we have a bunch of other topics
that you'll you'll see that connect it
to even more modern world topics things
that are relevant in your everyday life
so take a journey with us in U.S
government and Civics and I one you'll
learn a lot about the world you'll be
even more popular at dinner parties but
even most importantly you will you will
know how to participate in our democracy
and make us a more perfect union